THE MCDAVID LINE.
>> PROVIDED THREE G G
JOHNNY GAUDREAU WITH A MOVE. UN
LEGS OF NUGENT-HOPKINS AND SMITH
UNABLE TO HAVE
SCORED TWO QUICKLY
TRYING TO DO HERE IS ABSORB THAT
SHOT.
YOU CAN SEE OFF OF HIS B
FLANK.
MCLEOD BACK TO
HERE COMES RASMUS ANDERSSON.
KICKING IT BACK.KANE.
OFF A LEG TO THE END IT BACK BE
AND WATCH R
KNOCK IT AWAY FROM THE FLAMES
WINGER.
KYLINGTON SH AT BOTH SIDES.E BRH
TOFFOLI WANTED A CALL BUT ENDED
PERIOD.
3:02 OF THE FIRST AND N
GOALTENDER INTERFERENCE AS
MCDAVID COMES THROUGH. CONNOR M
COMING ACROSS.
MARKSTROCHALLENGE, NO RISK OF H
AND DRAISAITL UNABLE TO
TURNSTYLE PASS GUDBRANSON.
HAS IT AGAIN THERE.
BOUCHARD BUYS HIMSELF A LITTLE
TIME.
HOT SHOT LOOSETWO.
15 GOALS AGAINST THREE
GOALTENDERS.
KULAK. HEAD MANS
THE PUCK IN AND MCLEOD BACK IDE
BACK UP TO THE POINT AND A.
LINDHOLM ON THERE TO YAMAMOTO A
BACKNT RIGHT DOWN MAIN
STREET ANDECOND DAY OF FREE
AGENCY AFTER MARKSTROM CHOSE
CALGARY.
KEN HOLLAND OFFERED SMITH THE
DOWN LOW INTO THE SLOT.
THAT LITTLE TIPHE STICK OF TKAC.
HERE'S
OILERS CHANGING.
OUT COMES PUCK.
DOES HE GET THERE FIRST?
GUDBRANSON WANTED THE